Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan, wir stehen vor dem Salon und zunächst einmal habe ich eine Frage an dich,
mir ist bei YouTube schon vor längerer Zeit aufgefallen und ich wollte es dich
immer mal gefragt haben,
dass dort sehr viele Videos nun produziert werden,
in denen wir Menschen sehen, wie sie Musik zusehen, sie hören sich Musik an,
hören sich Clips an, Auftritte von irgendwelchen Sängerinnen und Sängern.
Sitzen davor und man sieht dann Live-Reactions.
Ich dachte erst, es handele sich um Musikanalysen, aber meist ist es nur, wow, amazing, wow.
Also, ich kenne das Genre, ich weiß, was du meinst, ich hab's aber aus meinem
Algo ganz schnell wieder raustrainiert, weil ich's dann doch quatschig finde.
In meinem Fall war es so, junge Frauen sitzen vorm Bildschirm,
beziehungsweise man sieht ja den Bildschirm nicht, man sieht die jungen Frauen,
und dann, was sie selber sehen, blenden sie noch mal zusätzlich ein und dann
gucken sie Comfortable Numb oder so von Pink Floyd,
also wo irgendwelche Gitarren-Solos kommen, die dann alle mitreißen und sie
gucken dann diese historischen Aufnahmen irgendwie Earls Chord 94 oder so,
keine Ahnung, wo sie selber noch ungeboren wahrscheinlich waren, schauen das dann.
Und ich habe, und das Musikvideo so, dauert schon neun Minuten und das Reaction-Video,
weil sie ja auch Pause macht und dann kurz, Oh, jetzt muss ich erst mal durchatmen
und so. Dauert dann 13 Minuten.
Und besonders witzig war, dass gleich in dem ersten Video, wo ich das doch ganz interessant fand,
dass sie es macht, also für mich sozusagen, diese David-Gelber-Musik noch mal
hört, hat sie dann gleichzeitig das Publikum adressiert im Sinne von,
sorry, dass ich das Musikvideo hier ausmache, weil es mich gerade so ergreift.
Aber ihr wisst ja, dass ich das in meinen Videos häufiger mache,
wo ich mir dachte, das ist ja Quatsch. Wenn mich das jetzt stören würde,
dass sie es ausmacht, kann ich ja das Original-Video, was sie selber guckt, gucken.
Also entschuldigt sie sich dafür, dass ich es ausmache. Das fand ich bei ungefähr
0,3 Sekunden darüber nachdenken so bescheuert, dass ich mir gedacht habe,
ich gucke mich noch mal kurz warm in das Genre und sortiere es dann aber wieder aus.
Das kann ich eh mal empfehlen. Man kann den YouTube-Algorithmus sehr gut trainieren,
indem man auf der Startseite einfach rechtsklickt, diesen Kanal nicht weiter
empfehlen, dieses Video ist uninteressant, Ja, denn ich gerate da immer wieder
in irgendwelche Dinge hinein, wo ich gar nicht hin will.
Oder man muss was recherchieren für den Podcast und möchte dann aber diesen
Kaninchenbau ganz schnell wieder verlassen, aber der Algorithmus braucht noch
fünf Monate dafür. Richtig.
YouTube weiß, also es gibt da auch viele, kennen wir ja selber die Geschichte,
wir haben ja selber schon vor Jahren da auf der Bühne drüber gesprochen,
dieses Repetol und so weiter.
Also YouTube gibt einem durchaus Handwerkszeug, um das ganz schnell wieder aussortieren.
Das habe ich in dem Fall dann konsequent gemacht, weil ich es dann doch irgendwie
quatschig finde. Ich weiß ja, also ich weiß, welche Musik mir gefällt.
Ich finde es trotzdem ein interessantes Genre, weil...
Warum geht man dahin was sucht man also man bekommt nicht
eine musikanalyse es gibt gewiss ein paar videos von
musikern die ein bisschen was erklären aber die meisten videos
versuchen zu zeigen dass wir
es dort mit menschen zu tun haben die emotional berührt sind oft ist es auch
so dass ich eine community über diese professionellen musikhörer herum bildet
die dann videos schickt ich bin ja wie du weißt ein fan der schlager der 60er
70er jahre und so sah ich beispielsweise,
irgendwelche Männer aus Kolumbien oder sonst woher, die plötzlich sich Wikileandros-
und Mireille Mathieu-Videos angesehen haben und dann unglaublich überrascht
taten oder es auch waren.
Und die Fans haben sich dann gefreut, dass sie diese unglaublichen Stimmen dort
dann mit einem Fremden erleben können.
Das hatte etwa ein bisschen diesen Effekt, ich schicke dir mal was,
das musst du dir unbedingt anhören, Und ich will aber auch, dass du begeistert
bist und bin dann eigentlich enttäuscht, wenn du es nicht bist.
Und das erfüllt so ein bisschen diese Funktion.
Also ich, also das ist jetzt auch ein Revitol als Thema an sich.
Es hat vielleicht ein bisschen mit Corona zu tun. Im Sinne von Musik alleine hören ist langweilig.
Ja.
Andere darüber kennenzulernen, welche Musik sie hören, ist nicht ungewöhnlich.
Andere parasozial, die man ja gar nicht kennt und auch nie kennenlernt,
aber wo man trotzdem so deren Geschmack so langsam versteht und dann einfach
wartet, mal gucken, was sie als nächstes für uns hören.
Und dann wartet man auf die nächste Veröffentlichung und dann,
ah ja, das ist ja auch eine Band, der ich mal nachgehen kann.
Also so als Einstiegsding oder so.
Ich war jetzt die Tage bei Herbert Grönemeyer im Konzert.
Oh je.
Er hat am Freitag hier gespielt.
Du nimmst aber jetzt auch wirklich alles mit.
Ich nehme jetzt alles mit. Und es ist ja ein bisschen so, dass wir derzeit gar
nicht genau wissen, in welchem Modus gehen wir eigentlich zu Live-Musik.
Für uns Operngänger ist es super easy, denn wir wissen, wenn wir in Frankfurt
in die Oper gehen, das wird dort ernst genommen. Jeder Huster,
wir haben es ja thematisiert, ist ein Problem.
Die Feststellung ist aber, wir leben in Zeiten, in denen man eigentlich so zu
Tokio Hotel geht, um nochmal zu gucken, ob sie noch leben, ob Heidi dabei ist,
wie Tom aussieht, ob sie seine Perücke noch trägt, keine Ahnung.
Man nimmt es nicht ernst, die auf der Bühne nehmen es nicht ernst.
Alle wissen, okay, für 60 Euro, das wird dann aufsummiert.
Wir alle zahlen unseren kleinen Obolus, müssen es deswegen nicht ernst nehmen
auf der Bühne, werden sie gut dafür bezahlt, dass sie uns so tun,
als würden sie es ernst nehmen, aber eigentlich wissen wir, denen ist auch scheißegal.
Das ist ja eigentlich dieser Modus. Und ich war ein bisschen überrascht,
dass man bei Herbert Grönemeyer
so alte Haudegen, sag ich mal, auf der Bühne sieht, die es wirklich ernst nehmen
und was auch eine Freude ist, das mal zu sehen, dass wirklich jemand auf die Bühne geht.
Ja, aber Bruno Mayer ist nicht ironisch.
Genau, einfach keine ironische Brechung. Der geht auf die Bühne und macht da
seine Show und er weiß genau, wer vor ihm steht.
Die Band macht ordentlich mit und das ist auch sehr entspannend.
Jetzt ist so, die Fans dort sind alle Altersklassen.
Also ja, meine Begleitung war neun. Und dann geht's natürlich Open End.
Leute werden mit Rollstuhl noch angefahren und so.
Dann wird es aber so laut, dass sich die Menschen nicht mehr unterhalten können,
während das Konzert läuft. Kennt man ja, man versucht sich noch ins Ohr zu schreien,
hört aber, na, es ist auch nicht gut.
Also regelt man das zwei Stunden lang über Gestik und Mimik.
Und es war mir doch eine große Freude, das mal zu sehen, wie irgendwelche Pärchen,
die sich gerade das kennengelernt haben, welche, die schon alt eingesessen sind, wie auch immer.
Also man sieht doch relativ viel Beziehungsgestaltung und so weiter.
Was ist denn hier los im Rahmen dieser Musik?
Also die Leute müssen über Gestik und Mimik, weil du ja eben meintest,
diese YouTube-Leute, die führen ja gar kein innerliches Argument aus.
Nö, machen sie nicht. Und das macht bei Herbert Grönemeyer auch keiner,
während die Musik läuft.
Also man hat so ganz viel dargestellte Gefühle plötzlich, wo dann man den Leuten
wirklich jahrelange Beziehungserfahrungen aus dem Gesicht sprechen und so.
Und das war wirklich hochinteressant. Das war ja auch für mich nach langem mal
wieder so ein Ja, so ein richtig großes Konzert. Ich habe ja Tokio Hotel leider
verpasst, weil die Oper so lange ging. Also solche Luxusprobleme.
Und in der Hinsicht würde ich sagen, ja, in diesen YouTube-Videos wird nicht über Musik gesprochen.
Da wird eigentlich gar nicht so viel gesprochen, aber man ist dabei,
wenn jemand fühlt und wie es halt so ist im Fernsehen, die verkaufen einem das
Verwöhn-Aroma und irgendwelche Parfums und man kann die nicht riechen.
Also müssen sie einem das darstellen, wie das so ist. In dem Falle kann man
die Musik noch zuhören und selber so ein bisschen abgleichen.
Fühle ich dasselbe, wie mir gerade vorgefühlt wird und dann stellt sich so ein
neues, vielleicht Vielleicht ist es auch so ein Andocken an so ein Weltgefühl irgendwie.
Da das gibt das man gemeinschaftlich fühlt bei den casting shows ist es ja auch
so dass man mit der jury mitfühlt oder immer diese vielen close ups kommen in
denen wir die tränen der jury mitglieder sehen all das ist etwas was man in
diesem genre auch hat ja.
Also das ja da könnte man wahrscheinlich eine ganz ausführliche.
Langgezogene, tiefgründige, bestimmt
auch Vergesellschaftungs- Mikro-Makro-Soziologie jetzt dazu machen.
Auch Interpassivität spielt eine Rolle. Fühl das mal für mich,
da muss ich selbst nicht machen. Fühl du mal für mich, wein du mal für mich.
Zu Mireille Mathieu, ich hab's schon früher mal gemacht. So kann man's auch machen.
Es gibt ja dieses schöne Lied von Udo Lindenberg, Du warst im Nana Muscuri-Konzert.
Ich hab dich gesehen und du hast geweint. Also dass
man sich auch vielleicht gar nicht traut selbst zu
fühlen und dann muss das ein anderer machen naja wo
es nicht so emotional zuging naturgemäß
war als unser kanzler einmal mehr eine historische europa rede gehalten hat
wir alle haben es nicht mitbekommen aber ich habe sie mir trotzdem angesehen
im europaparlament und ich habe nur ganz ganz wenig dabei wir müssen ganz kurz
drüber reden nur damit es abgehandelt ist und vielleicht so zwei Aspekte herausarbeiten.
Hören wir doch mal in den ersten Clip rein.
In der Schumann-Erklärung klingt das so.
Diese Produktion, gemeint sind Kohle und Stahl, wird der gesamten Welt ohne
Unterschied und Ausnahme zur Verfügung gestellt werden, um zur Hebung des Lebensstandards
und zur Förderung der Werke des Friedens beizutragen.
Europa wird dann mit vermehrten Mitteln die Verwirklichung einer seiner wesentlichen
Aufgaben verfolgen können, die Entwicklung des afrikanischen Erdteils.
Dieser Entwicklung des afrikanischen Erdteils stammt damals vor allem die von
Europa betriebene koloniale Ausdeutung unseres Nachbarkontinents entgegen.
Schon deshalb muss die Bewältigung der Folgen des Kolonialismus Wesensmerkmal
jeder europäischen Partnerschaft mit den Ländern Afrikas, Asiens und Lateinamerikas sein.
Einer Partnerschaft, die den eurozentrischen Blick der vergangenen Jahrzehnte hinter sich lässt.
Einer Partnerschaft, die Augenhöhe nicht nur behauptet, sondern herstellt.
Solche Partnerschaften zu errichten, scheint mir heute wichtiger denn je.
Also Schumann hat schon Eurozentrismus und jetzt nach ein paar Jahrzehnten ist
es in den Köpfen angekommen. Nein, das wissen wir gar nicht,
denn man kann ja überlegen, wo der Eurozentrismus heute in neuer Form wieder auftaucht.
Was Scholz doch klar ist, sind die Größenverhältnisse, wie wir im nächsten Clip hören.
450 nach einer nächsten Erweiterung vielleicht 500 Millionen Bürgerinnen und
Bürger leben in der Europäischen Union.
Das macht gerade einmal fünf Prozent der Weltbevölkerung aus.
In Asien, Afrika und im Süden Amerikas wachsen neue wirtschaftliche,
demografische und politische Schwergewichte heran.
Ein Erfolg übrigens der Arbeitsteilung zwischen Ländern und Kontinenten,
die eine Milliarde Menschen aus der Armut geführt hat.
Die ich aber nicht namentlich nenne, denn das ginge zu weit.
Ja, nun haben wir diese Größenverhältnisse erläutert bekommen und daraus kann
man ja nur schließen, dass es eine neue Weltordnung ist, in der wir leben.
Sie werden sich zu Recht nicht abfinden mit einer bi- oder tripolaren Weltordnung.
Deshalb bin ich fest überzeugt, die Welt des 21. Jahrhunderts wird multipolar sein.
Sie ist es schon längst. Doch was heißt das für uns in Europa?
Wird Europa das – und ich zitiere den französischen Schriftsteller Paul Valéry
–, was es wirklich ist? Ein kleines Vorgebirge, ein Kap des asiatischen Festlands?
Die Antwort darauf finden wir nicht beim Blick zurück.
Wer nostalgisch dem Traum europäischer Weltmachtnacht hängt,
wer nationale Großmachtfantasien bedient, der steckt in der Vergangenheit.
Und auch diejenigen, die permanent vor Europas Abstieg waren,
gewinnen nicht die Zukunft.
Also was machen wir damit?
Ja, wir haben jetzt gehört schon Robert Schumann sagt er achtet auch Afrika,
dann haben wir es aber neokolonial noch mal ausgebeutet nach der ersten Erfahrung.
Und jetzt erinnern wir uns einfach an Schumann und sagen jetzt machen wir es mal richtig irgendwie.
Gleichzeitig dann immer dieser große Brückenschlag, denn sonst macht China.
Und darüber oder darunter, das muss man eigentlich so sagen,
darunter im unsichtbaren, unausgesprochenen, latenten, wir haben es ja mit latenten
Sinststrukturen zu, die uns ansonsten nur die Psychoanalyse oder Ulrich Oevermann
mit der Objektivmärge benötigt.
Oder wie auch immer, hört man bei Olaf Scholz hier raus, wir sind nur fünf Prozent, wir sind wenige.
Und trotzdem haben wir einen Herrschaftsanspruch.
Aber dieser letzte Halbsatz bleibt unausgesprochen.
Dass dieses, wir finden jetzt mal einen neuen Platz in der Welt,
wohl wissen, dass es nicht mehr die Spitze ist.
Das ist zum einen rechtfertigungsbedürftig, ich muss es thematisieren, Aber nicht explizit.
Sondern dann findet Olaf Scholz solche Formulierungen wie hier.
Und dann fragt man sich immer so ein bisschen, was soll denn das eigentlich?
Und er antwortet Macron ganz deutlich, denn er zitiert ja hier nicht zufällig
einen französischen Schriftsteller, sondern er will durch den französischen
Schriftsteller eine kleine Mitteilung an Macron weitergeben.
Aber er entscheidet sich, Paul Valéry zu zitieren.
Ein Schriftsteller, der 1919 die Krise des Geistes schreibt,
ein sehr berühmter Essay über Europa und da heißt es dann tatsächlich wird Europa das werden,
was es in Wirklichkeit ist, nämlich ein kleines Vorgebirge auf dem asiatischen Kontinent,
Fragezeichen und dann oder wird es bleiben, was es zu sein scheint,
nämlich der auserwählte Teil der Erdkugel, die Perle der Sphäre,
das Gehirn eines riesigen Körpers.
Denn was Paul Valéry in in diesem Aufsatz machte,
ist zwar eine Krise des europäischen Geistes zu beschreiben,
aber er springt über den Nationalismus hinweg und versuchte an ein großes Europa
zu denken, das man verbinden kann mit all seinen Geisteskräften und er hat dann
auch so eine besondere Herleitung, warum Europa so einzigartig ist.
Das würde man sicherlich heute so nicht mehr schreiben, aber es ist doch ein bisschen verwirrend,
dass er, also Scholz, in seiner Antwort auf Macron sich gerade auf Pol Valéry bezieht,
ich sagen würde, Paul Valérys Idee ist doch eher an das anzuknüpfen,
was Macron davor hat, nämlich wieder ein starkes Europa und dass er aber so
eine merkwürdige Reihung vornimmt
von europäischen Souveränitätsträumen zu nationalistischen Fantasien.
Also wir haben so eine Reihung von das eine ist Macron, das andere ist urban,
das will ich auch nicht und das alles so abfrühstückt.
Das ist doch wieder eine solch klare Absage an.
Das was aus frankreich kommt nämlich ja doch immer mal wieder so eine handreichung
die dann abgeklärt wird wodurch dann auch sehr deutlich wird wie er sich wie
wir im nächsten clip hören werden das anstelle makrons idee vorstellt.
Wir brauchen eine geopolitische europäische union eine erweiterte und reformierte
europäische union und nicht zuletzt eine zukunftsoffene europäische union.
Okay, Zukunft soll das offen, da wird man ja fast, ja, kriegt man ja schon wieder
Gänsehaut, wenn man sowas hört.
Ja. Und nun zur Rolle der USA.
Auch im globalen Wettbewerb mit anderen großen Mächten muss Europa bestehen.
Die Vereinigten Staaten bleiben Europas wichtigster Verbündeter.
Und dabei gilt, in dem Maße, in dem wir nunmehr in unsere Sicherheit und Verteidigung investieren,
in zivile Resilienz, in technologische Souveränität, in zuverlässige Lieferketten,
in unsere Unabhängigkeit bei kritischen Rohstoffen, in diesem Maße sind wir
unseren transatlantischen Freunden bessere Verbündete.
Ja, ich frage mich, ob man diese Globalisierung im Geiste,
die da immer mitläuft, Dieses wir definieren unsere Rolle mal nur über die der
anderen und beginnen bei dem einfachsten der Mathematik, wir sind fünf Prozent
der Welt, wen interessiert es, würde ich sagen.
Die absolute Größe ist doch 500 Millionen, das hat er ja genannt 450 oder mit
der Ukraine 500 Millionen.
Ist 500 Millionen irgendwie zu klein oder was will er uns eigentlich sagen?
Er regiert 80 Millionen. Ist ihm das eigentlich zu wenig?
Hat er was gegen unsere Bürgermeister, die ja eigentlich die,
wie wir immer wieder sagen, Kämmererarbeit, Kümmerer, also Kümmerer und Kämmererarbeit,
die das alles erledigen?
Warum wird eigentlich in diesen komischen Maßstäben gedacht?
Warum kann man nicht einfach mal sowohl die Geschichte als auch die anderen,
also die Sach- und die Zeitdimension oder besser die Sozial- und die Zeitdimension
links liegen lassen, um selbstgenügsam auf einen selbst zu schauen.
Jeder psychologische Rat, wir werden heute noch ein bisschen über TikTok reden und so,
jeder psychologische Rat, den man in Krisenzeiten immer bekommt,
insbesondere wenn Jugendliche irgendwie nach Hilfe rufen und dann TikTok bemühen
und so, dann gucken Sie sich diese Videos an, wo es immer heißt,
vergleich dich nicht mit anderen, sei selbstgenügsam, auf deine eigene Stäre,
schreibt deine eigene Geschichte und so weiter und so fort.
Und politisch hat man genau das Gegenteil gemacht. Da fährt man irgendwo hin
und dann redet man die ganze Zeit über China und über die eigene Zwergigkeit
und so weiter, statt einfach zu sagen, also 500 Millionen, das ist so ein Maßstab,
in dem kann man ganz gut Binnenwirtschaft aufziehen.
Ja, läuft dann auch manchmal unter dem Hashtag Protektionismus.
Aber die anderen haben ja noch genug Absatzmärkte, wenn die 95 Prozent der Welt
sind. Also da muss man ja nicht allzu viel Rücksicht nehmen.
Das ist wirklich, man wünscht sich eigentlich,
dass Helmut Kohl, sag ich schon, Olaf Scholz mal mehr Reden hält,
dass man die dann auch vergleichen kann mit älteren, um da über die Kanzlerworte
hinaus wirklich mal so eine Art Psychologie zu machen, politische Psychologie.
Um einfach diesen latenten roten Faden, der da mitschwingt, mal gerade zu rücken,
weil der scheint mir so ein bisschen schief zu laufen.
Aber das finden wir ja jetzt nicht nur bei Scholz, ich vermute,
das hängt auch stark mit Thinktanks zusammen,
die immer wieder diese Zahlenspiele machen oder auch solche Intellektuelle wie
Gideon Rachman oder auch Pankaj Misha,
Misha Pankra, so rum, die ja
doch immer wieder deutlich machen so und
so viel asiaten wird es 2030 geben so
und so viel südamerikaner und wo
steht da der westen wo steht europa und dann
geht das gleich los dass man das miteinander vergleicht und das volkswirtschaften
jetzt wie die unseren probleme haben eigentlich genügend arbeitskräfte zu haben
deshalb denke ich sind diese zahlenspiele so sehr in den köpfen vorhanden ich
denke aber auch dass man ja ohnehin mit diesen zahlen nicht weiterkommt und
deswegen anders darüber nachdenken sollte.
Ich finde nur erstaunlich, dass hier auch noch mal ganz klar gesagt wird,
wir versuchen, zwar in Europa auch eine eigene Politik zu machen,
aber nur im Sinne einer Partnerschaft, die transatlantisch ist.
Also, dass man nicht jetzt hier von Scholz beispielsweise die Idee einer europäischen
Armee oder so etwas hört.
Das ist etwas, was ja nicht gern gesehen wird von der NATO. Es gab ja Anfang
der Nullerjahre schon mal solche Bestrebungen, was sehr klar von Washington
signalisiert wurde, dass man das nicht möchte.
Und Scholz bleibt eigentlich da auch wieder dieser Linie treu,
die ja die ganze Zeit die Linie der Bundesregierung war.
Während Macron da wirklich so eine Außenseiterposition in der EU zu spielen scheint.
Und auch sicherlich in Bezug auf China.
Unsere Beziehung zu China ist mit dem Dreiklang Partner-Wettbewerber systemischer
Rivale zutreffend beschrieben, wobei Rivalität und Wettbewerb seitens Chinas
ohne jeden Zweifel zugenommen haben.
Dies sieht die EU und darauf reagiert die Europäische Union,
mit Ursula von der Leyen bin ich mir einig, kein Decoupling,
aber ein kluges De-risking lautet die Debise.
Ja, De-risking, was für ein Quatschwort.
Das wurde ja jetzt in Washington auch übernommen, es ist glaube ich ein seltener
Fall, dass man in Europa ein Wort geprägt hat und das wurde dann in den USA übernommen.
Ja, aber wahrscheinlich wirklich nur, weil es Quatsch ist. Manchmal muss man
ja ein paar Kröten schlucken.
Wie zum Beispiel der NATO-Chef ist immer ein Europäer, dafür,
damit die Amerikaner dort machen können, was sie wollen.
Ich frage mich, wenn ich sowas höre, wir lesen gleich Dirk Oschmann.
Der hat ein Buch über den Osten geschrieben. Den Osten Deutschlands.
Wir haben es also mit deutsch-deutschen Verwicklungen zu tun.
Er zitiert einige, die sagen, dem deutsch-deutschen Krieg.
So, dann beginnt er mit dieser These, also wenn wir das mit dem Osten,
wenn wir unser Verhältnis, er meint Gesamtdeutsch, mit dem Osten nicht geregelt
kriegen, kriegen wir gar nichts mehr geregelt in Deutschland.
Was eine sehr starke These ist, sehr viele Ossis werden das wahrscheinlich hören
und denken, ja, finde ich gut, ja, das westdeutsche Schicksal hängt auch von mir ab.
Dann kommt Olaf Scholz und sagt, der Osten, ja, China, genau,
ich muss jetzt über China reden die ganze Zeit. Und da sind wir eigentlich genau
wieder in der Falle, die Dirk Oschmann hier aufmacht.
Ja, er hat ja an einer Stelle des Buchs auch so diese Idee, dass der Osten immer
woanders hin verlagert wird. Also der Osten auch in Städten eine Rolle spielt,
die irgendwo im Westen sind, dass man sagt, aber das ist der Osten der Stadt.
Der Stadt. Da zeigt es einen Unterschied.
Aber die die Himmelsrichtung hat doch so ein gewisses Geschmäckle.
Aber zu dem Buch kommen wir noch. Wir wollen noch einen Tipp uns von Olaf Scholz abholen.
Um es mit Oscar Wilde zu sagen.
Die Zukunft gehört denjenigen, die die Möglichkeiten erkennen,
bevor sie offensichtlich werden, sie gehört eben nicht den Nostalgikern.
Also schauen wir jetzt immer zurück und so weiter oder nicht?
Ne, wir antizipieren die Zukunft, man muss hinzufügen, ich habe es nachgesehen
und ich glaube es stimmt auch, was ich da gefunden habe, das Zitat ist nicht
von Oscar Wilde, das wurde irgendwann mal Oscar Wilde zugeschrieben, fälschlicherweise.
Aber das ist wahrscheinlich so, man schreibt eine Scholz-Rede und denkt,
jetzt brauchen wir noch irgendeinen Schluss, das ist so langweilig.
Und dann sucht man vielleicht bei gute-zitate.de irgendwas raus.
Das ist übrigens genau dieses, wir haben es ja jetzt ganz viel mit generativer
künstlicher Intelligenz zu tun.
Wir haben schon drüber gesprochen, bei Photoshop gibt man sein eigenes Familienfoto
rein und promptet sich dann einfach den Rest dazu.
Ja, GPT wird ja sehr häufig von Altman auch so als Sense-Making-Maschine,
Reasoning und so weiter. Das ist keine Suchmaschine, sondern es ist eine,
die in einem nochmal so in Sinnen roten Faden und so weiter weiterspielen kann.
Hier, das ist so ein klassischer Fall. Mal sehen, wie lange wir das noch in
Reden sehen. Es könnte sein, dass es jetzt nochmal anschwellt,
bevor es dann aufhört, dass man GPT einfach die zu 90% fertigen Geräte gibt und sagt.
Welches Zitat muss da am Ende rein? Und dann wird sinnhaft und zwar wirklich
dann ohne großes Halluzinieren auf die eigene Rede Bezug nehmend einfach fünf
Vorschläge gemacht, Oscar Wilde, Dings, Bums, Bangs und dann wählt man einfach aus.
Also diese Art von wir generieren uns was dazu wird, ist ja so einfach jetzt,
dass eigentlich solche Reden, die das als Pointe haben, jetzt schon Quatsch sind.
Und wenn, dann hätte er sich doch ruhig noch einmal auf Polvalerie beziehen
können, denn in diesem Text, die Krise des Geistes, steht ja auch der wunderbare
Satz, im Abgrund der Geschichte ist für viele Platz.
Ja.
Das gilt dann im Zweifel auch für Europa. Richtig. Jetzt müssen wir über unsere Lektüren reden,
aber zunächst müssen wir noch ganz kurz sagen, wie das mit dem Salon sich so
eigentlich verhält, denn es sind da Fragen aufgekommen.
Also erst einmal ist es möglich, jetzt diesen Monat den Salon gratis zu hören.
Man kann sich also dort registrieren, sowohl bei Apple als auch bei Steady.
Und dann kann man für einen Monat den Salon hören, auch die älteren Salons natürlich.
Und man wird dann auch unsere Live-Show nachhören können, die ja Ende,
Mitte, Ende des Monats stattfindet.
Das ist möglich, wenn man einfach auf die Seite zu Steady oder zu Apple geht
und dann findet man dort alles,
beziehungsweise wenn man von Spotify sich lotsen lässt auf die Steady-Seite,
dann kommt man dorthin und kann wählen, ob man gleich eine Mitgliedschaft abschließen
will, oder ob man erst einen Probemonat machen will.
Wenn man diesen Probemonat nicht kündigt, dann läuft das Abo weiter,
wenn man ihn kündigt, dann ist man wieder aus der Sache raus.
Richtig, wir haben ein kleines Foto-Update vor im Cover und werden dann im Zuge
der Empfehlungen von Apple und so auch den Salon als Salon vielleicht nochmal im Cover auch farblich,
ich schaue mir das nochmal an, was unsere Möglichkeiten so sind, so abheben,
dass nicht die Frage kommt, dann ist immer dieser Tag und dann kommen immer so zwei Folgen,
der kurze und der lange und ich verstehe das nicht, weil ja,
das eine ist eben dieser kleine Teaser,
in dem wir auch jetzt gerade hier zu hören sind und das andere ist eben hinter
der Paywall, die Salonfolge, die allerdings im Podcastplayer,
wir empfehlen ja sehr, die einfach im selbstgewählten Podcastplayer zu hören, was ja möglich ist.
Da taucht die halt einfach so auf, da ist sie halt nicht besonders gekennzeichnet.
Wir werden das nochmal so kennzeichnen.
Und den Salon war auch wirklich wohl im Titel immer Salon, wie wir das bei Apple schon machen.
Dass dann einfach da diese Konfusion zu Ende ist, und man nicht einfach nur
anhand der Folgenlänge errät, was man da eigentlich gerade hört.
Ja, also der Salon ist das Format, in dem wir über zehn wichtige Texte des Monats
sprechen. Das heißt, wir suchen uns immer gemeinsam ein Buch aus, über das wir sprechen.
Meistens ein Buch, das eine Debatte lostreten könnte oder schon losgetreten hat.
So in diesem Fall Dirk Oschmann und dann stellen wir noch jeweils Texte vor,
Bücher vor, die wir als relevant und wichtig empfinden und weil das auch schon
mal gefragt wurde, wie lange das denn so geht, das sind so zweieinhalb bis drei
Stunden sprechen wir in der Regel miteinander.
Und wer den Podcast unterstützen will, kann den Salon buchen,
auch wenn man den Podcast einfach so unterstützen will und vielleicht gar nicht
so viel Interesse am Salon hat.
Das ist jedenfalls die einzige Möglichkeit, um diesen Podcast zu unterstützen.
Und das ist jetzt auch möglich, dass man aber erst mal einen Monat gratis hört, was wir so treiben.
Und, warte, wir sagen noch mal kurzdrücklich dazu, denn ich war auch überrascht,
aber es ist, wie eben, also soeben erst von mir erfahren.
Wir müssen auch den Leuten, die nur von Freunden empfohlen bekommen haben,
den Salon zu hören, sagen, es gibt immer eine Woche vor dem Salon eine große
Folge, in der wir über den Monat reden.
Achso, das wissen manche nicht.
Also nicht Literatur oder sowas besprechen, sondern wirklich einfach nur die
Themen des Monats aufgreifen, von denen wir sagen, die müssen aber mal spontan
historisiert werden. Warum wurden die eigentlich übersehen?
Es gibt also, es ist ein bisschen kompliziert, wirklich zwei verschiedene Podcasts.
Im Prinzip schon. Und dieser längere Podcast, in dem wir über den Monat reden,
der ist auch vor der Paywall und überall zu finden, wo es Podcasts gibt.
Wir sprechen also über das Buch jetzt in diesem nächsten Salon gleich,
Der Osten, eine westdeutsche Erfindung von Dirk Oschmann.
Ich bin sehr gespannt, was die Debatte zwischen uns ergeben wird.
Du hast ja schon gesagt, du bist im Osten geboren.
Liest man dann das buch anders schreibe ich dir jetzt eine ost identität zu
sollte ich das tun ich habe ja eine west identität und ist das überhaupt so
habe ich eine west identität oder setze ich meine identität als absolut wir
werden über vieles diskutieren denke ich bei diesem buch des weiteren stelle ich vor.
Im Minusbereich, das ist ein Buch von Jana Kostas,
sie ist Professorin für Arbeit und Management,
und sie hat für einen längeren Zeitraum unter dem Potsdamer Platz gearbeitet,
um eine beobachtende Teilnahme anzufertigen, eine teilnehmende Beobachtung anzufertigen,
so rum, und zwar hat sie geschaut, wie arbeiten dort die Reinigungskräfte,
und sie hat aber auch genauso mitgearbeitet.
Und es ist dabei aber jetzt nicht irgendein Betroffenheitsbuch herausgekommen,
sondern eine sehr, sehr interessante Analyse, die auch viele kontraintuitive Aspekte hat.
Ich werde vorstellen, ein Roman von Arnold Stadler, irgendwo aber am Meer,
ein Schriftsteller ist auf einer Lesung und bekommt eigentlich vorgeworfen,
dass er nicht Greta Thunberg ist.
Und man hat so ein bisschen den Eindruck, oh, hat er jetzt so einen Boomer-Roman
geschrieben? Er ist immerhin 1954 geboren.
Aber nein, dieser Roman rührt dann ans Existenzielle.
Außerdem noch ein Text über Entertainment in chinesischen Autos.
Ein Text zum Thema Austerität und Klassenkampf von oben.
Und ein Interview mit einem Trendforscher, der einen neuen Patriotismus bei
den jungen Leuten sieht.
Mhm, gut. Wie kann so was passieren, dass irgendwer neue Einstellungen hat?
Ich habe Texte, von denen mir erst vorhin dann auffiel, die fallen ja alle so
unter das gleiche Thema irgendwie.
Welches Verhältnis haben wir eigentlich von unserer Welt und was wissen wir über sie?
Wir lesen also diese große Otto-Brenner-Studie von Janis Brinkmann,
also Otto Brenner Stiftungsstudie von Janis Brinkmann über Funk journalistische
Grenzgänger, wie die Reportageformate von Funk Wirklichkeit konstruieren.
Funk besteht ja aus ungefähr 80 verschiedenen Versuchen, junge Menschen zu erreichen.
Und vier, fünf davon machen so was, was man weithin unter politischem oder sonstigen
Journalismus und nicht unter Unterhaltungsprogrammen verbucht.
Die wurden in Gänze angeschaut.
Also jedes einzelne Video mehr als tausend.
Dann, wir hatten über TikTok gesprochen in der Folge, die wir am Mittwoch aufgenommen haben.
Dann kam am Donnerstag eine neue Zeit.
Sie ist ganz in rot gehalten auf Seite eins. Und Achtung, TikTok steht da drauf.
Mit einem Verweis aufs Dossier.
Ich habe also entschieden, diesen Text lesen wir, egal, wie ich ihn finde.
Wir lesen also gleich die drei Seiten TikTok-Dossier in der Zeit von Miguel
Helm und Kerstin Kohlenberg.
Dann hat die Washington Post einen interessanten Text, der immer mal wieder
im Podcast angesprochen wurde, jetzt so die letzten Tage, von Christopher Meems
mit der deutschen Überschrift. Ich hab's mir per Deep Hill direkt auf Deutsch
übersetzt, damit wir es hier leichter lesen können.
Hilfe, meine politischen Überzeugungen wurden von einem Chatbot verändert.
Und interessanterweise mit der Pointe im Text, was ist denn eigentlich,
wenn wir die letzten Umfragefragen von dem Pew Research Center auch einfach
jetzt den neuen AIs stellen? Was antworten die eigentlich so?
Und im Vergleich zu den Amerikanern, das ist ein ganz interessantes Design.
Und dann gucken wir am Ende nochmal, Klaus Dörre hat in den Blättern,
Grün als Bedrohung, warum die Klimapolitik die Arbeiter verliert.
Und wir können mal überprüfen, steht da eigentlich noch Überraschendes drin?
Gibt es in dieser ganzen Diskussion, wie wir sie haben, irgendetwas,
was uns nochmal überrascht im Sinne von,
Ja, wenn man eine politische Diskussion so führt, verliert man die Leute,
die einfach acht Stunden am Tag arbeiten, und zwar ab 6.30 Uhr dann mittags
also müde nach Hause kommen und abends nochmal die eine Stunde.
Jetzt will ich aber 220 km auf der Autobahn fahren, ansonsten bin ich unzufrieden.
Also passt das irgendwie noch zusammen. Wir werden überprüfen,
ob es dazu noch irgendwas zu sagen geht oder ob unsere politischen Diskussionen
mittlerweile auf dem offensichtlichsten angekommen sind und wir uns alle einfach
nur mal an den Kopf fassen können. So sieht's aus.
Dann sehen wir uns im Salon. Bis gleich.
Bis gleich.